[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
december is upon us the final month of
2020
has a handful of games vying for your
attention and one game may very well be
the best game ever made
only time will tell finding a free game
this month has been tough but the
tradition continues
something for everyone even if you don't
have a pocket full of cash
let's do this first up
is cyberpunk 2077 yep i know what you're
thinking
again this game has had so many delays
it's becoming a running joke now
but on december the 10th the wait is
finally over
a first-person role-playing game with
such deep rpg elements
that it will take around eight hours to
simply understand the potential of the
world you drop into
the early part of the game asks us to
choose a backstory for our v
character which could be nomad with mad
max vibes in the desert
maybe a street kid instead with gang
affiliation and street smarts
or what about corporate a top of the
line money's no issue kind of position
but each of these choices impacts the
entire game such as the nomad knowing
people from outside night city
and the street kid having knowledge of
street level crimes
these are part of the journey as story
and player choice
are the real focus in cyberpunk but of
course there is combat with a range of
weapons and even
swords but violence can be avoided with
wit and stealth
and a few cybernetic enhancements i'll
be breaking down 50 things you should
know before the launch
which is december the 10th on
playstation xbox pc
and stadia did you hear about the game
gods and monsters
a few e3's back well that had a name
change and is now immortals phoenix
rising
i'm sure you nintendo fans recognize the
inspiration behind this game
zelda breath of the wild without a doubt
a huge part of immortals phoenix rising
is based on that but also combined with
assassin's creed mechanics
for example you have a bird companion
who acts much like those seen in
assassin's creed valhalla and origins
the real hook here is the links to greek
mythology the story has phoenix rescue
greek gods from the titan typhon who
seeks revenge on zeus
but don't expect a serious story from
the early previews the narrator in game
is here for comedic value too immortals
phoenix rising releases on december 3rd
on everything pc xbox switch stadia and
of course good old playstation
[Music]
it's been four long years since we last
saw a worms game
back then worms was a turn-based
strategy title with over-the-top weapons
and
impossible clutch plays using the wind
in 2020
worms have gone real time no more
waiting for your turn
this time worms is a battle royale game
well
yeah amongst other traditional game
modes like deathmatch it
is 32 players pile into a platformer
style level with shortcuts and power-ups
everywhere
squad modes have been confirmed too with
good old reviving mechanics
and potentially a more tactical approach
who am i kidding this is this is chaos
if you like the art style and crazy
weaponry from the og wormsdays you'll be
happy to see it all kicked into 2020
in a whole new way worm's rumble hits
shelves on december the 1st
on pc and playstation 4 and playstation
5. it's a 15
game so in the uk that would be about 10
quid
next we have temtem you may have heard
of this one in the past due to
crowdfunding which pushed this over the
line
temtem is a pokemon game well obviously
not officially
it's attempting to recreate the pocket
monster games you know and love
and evolve them in its own way this
means it can exist on other platforms
other than nintendo so on december the
8th the early access console release on
ps5
which will have cross play built into pc
communities
we'll be traveling across a huge world
discovering and fighting over 100
pokemon i mean temtem
and battling and working with other
players online
there was talk that the final version of
temtem would move to a free-to-play
model
but right now it's only a paid early
access option
judging by the cosmetic packs they are
currently trying to shift
i do hold out hope that in 2021 we will
be talking about this game
as a free game we shall see
[Music]
i suppose we should talk about free
games now then i have to admit i
struggle to find free stuff this month
this is due to such high quality games
in the past like rogue company a team
tactical shooter which gives a great
break from battle royale free games
please try that game if you haven't
already this month the free game of
choice
is rpg maker mv player yep that's the
title
it's a terrible title but let me explain
back in september
rpg maker released which allows players
to build their own rpgs
in game on ps4 switch and pc now that
client has been updated
and everyone even if you don't have the
original game can play these created
games using the player app
i know this is a very niche audience but
i'm really hoping someone
likes the old jrpg style and wants to
play an unlimited amount of them for
free if you prefer modern rpgs though
you should totally download genchin
impact it's also free
and legit one of the best rpgs of the
year
here's a very interesting concept for a
game cronos before the ashes
this is a sequel to the well-received
remnant from the ashes
but the reason i'm bringing this up is
due to a mechanic it has
after every death in game your character
ages by one year
just think about that for a moment it's
mind-blowing
every 10 years new abilities become
available and perks change your
character's approach to battle
but on the flip side your speed and
stamina reduces
as your years progress but with that age
comes wisdom and knowledge of the
in-game
mana system i really thought this give
and take was worth acknowledging
there has been zero hype leading up to
this zero promotion either
but if you think the name sounds
familiar you're right the game is a
remake of a vr title no less
back when we all thought vr was the
future of gaming maybe not
chrono chronos before the ashes arrives
on december 1st
on playstation pc xbox switch and even
stadia
[Music]
a few nods of appreciation to other
games before we finish
twin mirror lost on arrival is a third
person adventure game in which we play
as a journalist named sam
twin mirror plays a great deal like
david cage games
like fahrenheit or heavy rain with
similar multiple endings to find and
play out
there's also a strong suggestion that
december will bring the reveal
and release of red dead redemption
remastered on ps5 and xbox series x
on december 10th i tried to get this
confirmed i've had no luck
fingers crossed it's true and finally
empire of sin
set in chicago during the prohibition
era in the us
where crime families rose up and
controlled towns and cities
the best way to describe empire of sin
is by
imagining x-com but with free movement
outside of combat
this marries together the chaos and
highly tactical shooting elements with
story-driven gameplay and decision-based
speech
it's possible to talk things out with
other crime families without shooting a
bullet
and even work together to take out
another mob boss
sounds like an interesting approach
doesn't it empire of sin releases on
december the first
on playstation xbox pc and switch so
there we have it a bunch of new games
trying to grab your attention over
christmas and beyond i'm gonna go hard
at cyberpunk 2077
i hope you choose to come back and check
out some of my content let me know what
you're playing this month and thank you
very much for sticking to the end of the
video much appreciated
i'm adam from playstation grenade thanks
for your time